So I get to talk about what Sergio called the Tesla of myeloma cars.
You know, this is, you know, a Nita cell, which, you know, is our exciting hope for a car that is maybe going to have the horsepower of Carvicti, but with sort of better handling and sort of reliability on the open road.
And I'm going to be presenting cleanest slides.
So basically, this is, you know, this is this is data from the Imagine One trial.
You know, we're talking about the clinical data supporting a Nita cell.
It's largely from that.
And so, you know, in terms of what's unique about a Nita cell in comparison to Ida cell and Cilta cell, you know, what's thought to be part of the potentially unique characteristics is the the synthetic D domain binder.
So it's smaller than the the murine, you know, construct of Ida cell or the camelid bivalent heavy chain constructs with Carvicti.
And essentially that smaller, you know, sort of.
Linker is thought to help or binder is thought to help to contribute to higher transduction efficiency, greater percentage of car positivity, lower cell dose being able to be administered, less tonic signaling and, you know, a fast off rate combined with high surface expression, which may allow good cell killing while less, you know, having less prolonged inflammation potentially.
So but the initial indication of the potentially potent effectiveness of an Ida cell came in the phase one study, which, you know, evaluated.
The patient's four plus prior lines of therapy and showed a medium progression free survival amongst these patients of about 30 months, you know, about an 80% CRSCR rate and importantly, you know, gave the first indication that there were no signals for non-ICANN's neurotoxicity, including Parkinsonism, cranial neuropalsy, Guillain-Barre being observed in these patients.
So that led to the Imagine One phase two trial.
You know, this was a relatively straightforward design.
You know, patients.
Needed to have three or more prior lines of therapy, including an image, a PI, a CD38 monoclonal antibody.
They underwent leukapheresis and then manufacturing bridging was strongly encouraged.
And then, you know, lymphodepletion followed by cell administration target dose of 115 times 10 to the six car cells, 129 patients, leukapheresis, 118 got LD, LDC, and then all but one got cells.
Median follow up in this presentation was about 16 months from administration.
I'm administration of cells and these are the patient characteristics.
So median of three prior lines of therapy, you know, and, you know, we're not supposed to, you know, listen, this is going to be data that's leading to an approval.
That's going to, we're going to be forced to make decisions in the clinic.
And so when we do that, what we're going to be comparing it to is cartitude one, which is the late line study of Carvicti that led to its initial approval.
You know, and what is different is the median number of prior lines of therapy.
But what's a little bit similar is the, you know, sort of the class exposures that patients have.
You know, so basically patients who are enrolled in 2023 were packing a lot more into their lines, their three lines of therapy than we were packing into lines of therapy in 2019.
So, you know, very pretty kind of strikingly similar amount of triple class refractory 88 versus 87% of patients, penta refractory 42 versus 41 and characteristics like extramedullary disease rates.
So, you know, what, what, what happens when you put these cells into people is that everybody responds, you know, 96% overall response rate.
You know, time.
Time to first response is quick pair of proteins clear gradually.
So time to best response takes, you know, half a year.
And, you know, the large majority of patients who are MRD evaluable, which is not all patients, but, you know, 96 of the patients had MRD assessment capability.
95% were MRD negative at 10 to the minus fifth, which again, compares pretty favorably to cartitude one where, you know, 92% of MRD evaluable patients at 10 to the minus fifth were MRD negative.
They also assess, you know, we have limited flexibility.
So we have a six month, you know, MRD sustained negativity rate of 83%, which was, you know, a little bit higher, but on a, you know, it was, you know, limited patients.
So there's always some sampling limitations.
We don't have a Kaplan-Meier curve.
We, I think most of us would have, we're hoping we would.
So instead we have time point estimates for, you know, expected PFS.
And again, a lot of these happen to overlap with time points that were reported out for cartitude one.
So, and they line up pretty comparably.
You know, we do have an 18.
Month PFS of 67 versus 66%, a 24 month of 61 versus like 60.5.
So again, I, I don't want to overstate the similarities because we have gotten a lot better at taking patients through CAR Ts over this period of time and optimizing them during the bridging period, you know, of selecting patients, you know, you can have the same lines of therapy, but this was a pretty clean cohort that we were, that we were choosing for this.
But those are the similarities at, but the difference is, is here, you know, so basically CRS rates.
You know, large majority of patients get CRS, um, mostly grade one, grade two, one patient had grade five.
This led to some scrutiny of how best to navigate patients through this, this treatment, um, happens a little bit earlier than Carvicti, a little bit later than Idacel, uh, about four day, day four is the average time of onset, um, very clean neurotox profile to date, you know?
So basically, you know, a handful of patients had ICANs, one patient with grade three, and so far no patients have been observed to have Parkinsonism.
Cranial nerve palsies, Guillain-Barré, uh, IEC enterocolitis, so that's exciting, um, you know, and then, you know, all the things that are unavoidable with a BCMA CAR-T, you're going to get with a BCMA CAR-T, there's going to be pancetopenia after your LDC, and some with your inflammation from CAR, there's going to be some infection risk, um, so, you know, we're now undertaking or, you know, nearing completion of enrollment for the Imagine 3 confirmatory phase three.
This is going to be a need to sell versus dealer's choice of, you know.
Combo in the, for one to three prior lines of therapy setting, um, would be just shocking if it's not a positive trial down the road.
So where do we stand?
You know, PDUFA date is set for December 23rd, so the hope would be that this is our Christmas gift, that we're going to have a need to sell in our stockings, uh, for, for myeloma patients and, and treatment doctors.
Um, you know, exactly what the approval, um, you know, setting will be is, is hard to say, but, you know, hope would be that we have enough data to, to lead to an approval.
Uh, obviously it's entering a crowded space, it's going to be, you know, sort of, um, you know, contending with CARVICTI in an earlier line approval, how we decide to navigate patients, but, you know, there's no way that it's not a good thing to have a CAR with this, you know, efficacy profile that we've seen to date and with hopefully a more straightforward toxicity profile.
But I would say, I think most of us are, are waiting a bit to see what happens when the rubber hits the road.
We know from, um, you know, Queen and others in the immunotherapy consortium, that 70 plus percent of our patients in the real world would not fit the criteria that we would need to fit for this trial.
Things like enterocolitis with CARVICTI, we found out after approval.
So, you know, exactly how much, uh, you know, sort of, of the things that we're used to waiting through with CARVICTI, we might see with a need to sell in our real world scenarios.
Um, we'll find out.
Okay.